das ist ein kleiner Bleistift aber der
Beginn von etwas ganz großen denn viele
Hilfsorganisationen bauen Schulen in den
Entwicklungsländern aber was dann Maren
Reißner hat festgestellt die Lehrer dort
haben auf gar keine Ahnung von dem was
sie da unterrichten sprich Schülerinnen
und Schüler lernen nichts um das zu
ändern hat sie Bleistift for everyone
gegründet und das verrückte der
Unterricht ist noch nicht mal das
Wichtigste an den Schulen what los
geht's
[Musik]
vielen Dank an unseren Zuschauer Stefan
der Marens Projekt Bleistift for
everyone vorgeschlagen hat angefangen
hat alles mit einer Urlaubsreise Maren
Reisner hat ihre Familie eingepackt um
um die Welt zu reisen und das nicht zu
Erholung wir wollten unseren Kindern
auch einfach die Welt zeigen und mal
zeigen wie die verschiedenen Kulturen
sind wie die Menschen sind was sie so
wirklich beschäftigt und deswegen haben
wir auch immer versucht möglichst nah an
den Menschen zu leben
braucht dann natürlich mit vielen
Mitbewohnern und vielen
Kakerlaken und Insekten aber das ist der
Preis um ganz nah die Menschen zu sein
Maren erinnert sich an ihren eigenen
Erdkundeunterricht und stellte fest dass
sie hier in Afrika Zeugin des Teufels
Kreises der Armut wurde angefangen damit
dass wir in in einer in Tansania an der
Grenze zu Malawi in der Missionsstation
waren und da gab es auch eine Schule mit
eben auch wieder so 200 Kindern in einem
Raum und keiner sprach ordentlich
Englisch und ich habe zu dem Fahrrad
Emission gesagt ja der Englischlehrer
spricht gar kein Englisch und der sagte
ja also außer mir spricht ja keiner
Englisch und das war nicht der einzige
Englischlehrer der kein Englisch sprach
sondern das waren einfach irgendwie sehr
viel auf der Reise und zwar so der erste
Punkt wo ich gedacht habe da kann man
die Schule gehen und trotzdem wird
nichts aber rauskommen wenn noch nicht
mal der Lehrer das kann was unterrichten
soll na Bildung ist einfach die Basis
von allem also es merkt man ja auch so
bei diesen ganzen
der Teufelskreis der Armut das haben wir
alle in der Schule gelernt dass wenn die
Menschen keine Bildung haben dann können
sie nicht arbeiten wenn sie nicht
arbeiten dann zahlen Sie keine Steuern
an den Staat dann hat der Stadt kein
Geld und kann ich denn die Bildung
investieren und sobald sich halt die
Katze in den Schwanz und das begegnete
ihr immer wieder in zahlreichen Ländern
während ihrer einjährigen Weltreise
reifte in ihr der Entschluss ich wollte
ja von Anfang an wollte ich nicht so ein
reines Charity-Projekt machen und also
nicht rein Spenden sammeln ich wir sind
ja gemeinnützig das heißt wir bekommen
auch viele Spenden aber ich wollte dass
man was was kauft was man auch braucht
also was und ich auch unseren Müllberg
noch größer macht und was gleichzeitig
was Gutes tut und deswegen lassen wir ja
in Deutschland Blöcke und Bleistifte
produzieren und für jeden Block geht ein
US-Dollar an den Erhalt einer unserer
Bildungsprojekte und pro Bleistift
bekommt ein Kind in einem
Entwicklungsland einen Bleistift
geschenkt denn Bildung scheitert oft
schon am nicht vorhandenen Bleistift und
Papier nicht einmal diese einfach Dinge
können sich Eltern leisten mit den
Spendengeldern werden nicht vorrangig
Schulen gebaut sondern zuerst wird alles
getan um ein gutes Lehren und Lernen
überhaupt zu ermöglichen wie zum
Beispiel ausreichend Lehrkräfte und
deren Schulungen Unterrichtsmaterialien
für die Kinder und etwas das noch viel
wichtiger ist wir sorgen also an unseren
Schulen dafür dass die Kinder also falls
wirklich ein Mittagessen bekommen weil
dieses Essen ist der Punkt warum sie
überhaupt oft überhaupt zur Schule
kommen wir haben auch zum Beispiel
Schulen in Nepal und da sagte Direktorin
seit wir für alle Kinder Essen anbieten
sind alle Kinder zurückgekommen in den
Unterricht und nur wenn sie kommen dann
können wir sie bilden das heißt dieses
ganz wesentlich ist dieses schultägliche
mitessen das finanzieren wir
Patenschaften also für 10 € immer im
Monat kann man eins unserer Schulkinder
an jedem Schultag mit dem Essen
versorgen deshalb unterstützt dieses
wirklich wichtige Bildungsprojekt er
Bleistift for everyone gerne der Link
ist hier und in der Videobeschreibung
und für ganz besondere unter
unterstützende gibt es auch eine
Auszeichnung diesen silbernen Bleistift
ich würde mich freuen wenn Ihnen sich
viele von euch verdienen zum Beispiel
mit einer Patenschaft alle Infos dazu
unter dem Link bis dann bleibt dran